il y a 6 mois le président macron devant
le parlement européen a indiqué son
souhait d'inscrire le droit à
l'avortement dans la charte des droits
fondamentaux de l'union européenne et
nous avons été nombreux et nombreuses à
applaudir à ce moment depuis il ya eu
l'effroyable décision de la cour suprême
aux états unis qui a été pour nous un
choc brutal aucune démocratie n'est
désormais à l'abri le lobby
international anti ivg anti choix et
puissant il dispose de moyens financiers
importants de relais idéologiques
politiques et religieux personne ne peut
dire ce qui se passera en france demain
ou après demain
plusieurs propositions de loi ont été
déposées et j'associe dans mon propos
mes collègues du groupe communiste les
collègues du groupe europe ecologie les
verts qui aussi travail ainsi que tous
les groupes de l'assemblée nationale
mais inconsciente 58 est ainsi faite que
ce n'est pas le parlement qui a la plus
facile initiatives en matière de réforme
de la constitution
la démarche la procédure la plus
efficace c'est celle du projet doit
aussi madame la première ministre ma
question est très simple et je vous
demande solennellement pensez vous
inscrire à l'ordre du jour un projet de
loi pour un sport définitivement
garantir dans la constitution le droit à
l'avortement et à la contraception
or les regarder sous vise la justice
monsieur dupont moretti vous avez la
parole monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
rossignol l'histoire fourmille
d'exemples de libertés fondamentales que
l'on croyait acquise et qui ont été
balayés comme tu autant de fétus de
paille l'exemple américain nous rappelle
que même dans les grandes démocraties ce
que l'on croyait acquis depuis 50 ans en
réalité ne l'est pas le droit d'aller vg
est un droit fondamental
bien sûr et personne je dis bien
personne ne peut envisager de retirer
aux femmes le droit de disposer de leur
corps c'est la raison pour laquelle le
président de la république et vous
l'avez rappelé en janvier avant même la
décision américaine indiqué qu'il
envisageait de l'inscrire dans la charte
des droits fondamentaux de l'union
européenne
c'est la raison pour laquelle madame la
première ministre elle aussi a dit que
le gouvernement soutiendrait toutes les
initiatives parlementaires engagés sur
cette question je pense à la proposition
de loi de la présidente bergé mais en la
matière madame la sénatrice toutes les
volontés sont bonnes à prendre et je
sais nous savons tous ici votre
engagement en la matière alors certains
diront et vous l'avez rappelé que le
l'exemple américain n'a pas sa place en
france en réalité on va le dire rien en
la matière n'est jamais acquis la
liberté la démocratie les droits
fondamentaux sont toujours fragiles et
mérite notre vigilance nos institutions
fonctionnent c'est vrai différemment le
droit à lille et j'ai est ici mieux
protégés et je sais que ma collègue
isabelle rome se bat au quotidien pour
donner à toutes les femmes un égal accès
à l'île et g mais de grâce et vous
l'avez dit ne prenons pas de risques
c'est pourquoi en tant que garde des
shows je soutiendrai avec force ces
initiatives pour les voir aboutir le
parlement est dans son rôle le
gouvernement sera dans le chien pour
qu'enfin le droit ben ali vg devienne un
droit inaliénable
rossignol même la présidente
monsieur le garde des sceaux je me
réjouis du fond de votre réponse mais
n'en prenez pas ombrage je vais
m'adresser à la première ministre rien
de personnel monsieur le garde des
sceaux soyez en certains madame la
première ministre j'ai fait comprendre
que vous cherchiez des majorités de
projets je vous en propose une à cet
instant une belle majorité de projets
qui vous permettrait sur un projet de
loi et pourquoi j'insiste sur le projet
de loi parce que la procédure parle
d'initiatives parlementaires n'aboutira
pas personne ne veut un référendum sur
l'accès à l'ivg et j'ai donc la seule
solution pour que vos engagements soit
concret pour que votre mandat à matignon
ne soit pas simplement le mandat d'une
deuxième femme première ministre mais
celui d'une deuxième femme première
ministre qui a fait avancer les droits
des femmes je vous le redemande fait un
projet de loi
[Musique]